[Music]
hey true believers I'm Lorraine and this
is the Marvel minute bringing you 60
seconds of Marvel news and we are
officially in the endgame now if you
haven't already you need to buy those
tickets and get yourself to the theater
to see Marvel Studios Avengers and game
what a massive opening weekend
congratulations to everyone involved in
a big thank you to the fans for doing
whatever it takes and now it is time to
get savage you do not want to miss this
killer new series kicking off with
savage Avengers number one written by
the incredible Jerry Duggan who you
might remember from his epic Deadpool
run as well as the amazing Mike Deodato
this story is gruesome and action-packed
and if you want to get it the free
there's also going to be a preview of
the series with an issue releasing for
Free Comic Book Day this Saturday and in
Marvel games news Ronan is coming in
Marvel contest of Champions on may 2nd
and Marvel Studios Avengers endgame
inspired content continues to release in
Marvel contest of Champions Marvel
future fight Marvel battle lines Marvel
Strikeforce and Marvel Puzzle Quest go
download those games on the App Store
and on Google Play and that's all the
time we have for this week but I will
see you next time on the Marvel minute